on verra tout ce que ce vendredi on a
encore beaucoup de choses à évoquer en
sorte notamment le business de serre il
n' ya quand j'ai vu les chiffres que je
suis tombé de ma chaise tombé de ma
chaise avant de poursuivre le zapping
c'est un événement national je tenais à
faire une déclaration solennelle que cet
officiel
magali bernard un scoop
[Musique]
je suis tellement ému mon avis à mon
avion c'est propre et jean yole mai
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lorsqu'on s'arrête en place ses
collègues et de voir le mouvement nazi
oui c'est ça c'est ça le bush comme
barbie mais reconnaissez mois - talent
je vous dis je peux faire une petite
confidence
oui j'ai vu des photos de vous dis date
qui datent de ya trois ans à paris
montre qu'on veut voir alors non mais
j'ai pas comme ça mais j'ai vu le avant
après et honnêtement c'est très réussi
avant vous est 13e à venir et bien avant
mais en gt 900 mhz et l'honnête vous
l'assumez alors qu'aimé votre mon scoop
c'est que tf1 est dans la merde
lucie catastrophe il ya des notes
internes qui tourne de partout les
émissions sont déprogrammés hausse des
émissions qui ont été tournées sont
toutes des programmes et parce qu'ils
ont plus de pub dont danse avec les
stars le tournage devait avoir lieu en
novembre et il n'ya pas tournage danse
avec les stars
donc ils ont annulé par lorient danse
avec les stars et aurait des émissions
sont proches de budget et ben oui parce
qu'à plus d'annonceurs c'est compliqué
ils ont tourné par exemple la ville à
des crises et vous connaissez bien qui
devait diffuser la semaine prochaine
pareil annulé alors maintenant
confirmant que j'avais la téléralité a
pour l'instant on n'a pas de date là
rien donc tous les candidats en tournée
est bon et il n'y a pas d'émission mais
juste les émissions ont été payés par la
chaîne oui il n'ya pas de même pour
l'instant ils mettent tous en stock on
sait pas et surtout ça très dommage
parce que c'est maintenant que les gens
ont besoin de regarder ce genre de
programme en plus a déjà été tourné donc
ça mais c'est alors que doivent être
remplacés par les films de noël j'adore
est-ce qu'on a une idée de la baisse
pour le coup c'est un sujet la baisse de
la pub sur les chaînes auriez on est
tous concernés on passerait jeu parce
que si ça marche pas pour tf1
les autres sûr que la concrètement la
baisse est assez phénoménal parce
qu'aujourd'hui les chaînes ou un revenu
publicitaire sur la télé mais aussi sur
tout ce qui est digital sur le digital
on est de plus en plus ce qu'on appelle
sur le good good life on dirait un truc
américain en gros dés qu'il ya une
ambiance un petit peu anxiogène les
investisseurs ne veulent plus investir
là dessus c'est valable aussi pour les
players sur internet etc
donc ils prennent vraiment global donc
là aujourd'hui effectivement c'est tout
à fait logique vu la période sont en
train de traverser bien sûr donc qu'il
mette en stock et diffuseront plus tard
sur bien sûr pas concernant das ara
aprikian a dit que ça allait être décalé
plus heures dans l'année que c'était pas
abandonner mes dessins c'est un scoop
nicolas je rappelle à diriger l'unité de
divertissement de france 2 ces
situations d'endettement pour le pour
les chaînes c'est une place marché parce
que c'est effectivement catastrophique
après je pense qu'il ya aussi d'autres
raisons c'est quand vous regardez danse
avec les stars mais avec le problème qu
vie d'aujourd'hui de personnes dix
danseurs un peu compliqué c'est surtout
de recruter des stars parce qu'elle a
toutes les émissions bf1 ya toujours de
mostar maintenant un peu partout mais
y'a jamais de stars de nom mandri est
les vedettes mais ya pas de staël sqs
que de la même façon que certaines
grandes entreprises font ménage dans les
boîtes parce qu'il ya le comider se
servent de ça pour licencier est ce que
quand et où penser que les chaises rage
mais elle est loin
profitez du coc vite pour se débarrasser
des déboulés de la programmation va pas
non mais ça je pense pas mais par contre
je pense qu'on peut dire qu'entre 20 et
50 % des revenus publicitaires la baisse
des revenus puis si certes seraient
entre 20 et 50% je dirais depuis le 1er
janvier ce qui est jusqu'à l'os à ses
colosses à nous est cédée rien en euros
et prenait les dizaines de millions
d'euros des dizaines de millions d'euros
dont il ya juste un moment donné quand
vous avez des missions qui coûte un
million d'euros par exemple si vous
n'avez pas de revenus publicitaires qui
couvrent ne serait-ce que le coût du
programme c'est un petit peu compliqué
il faut pas faire les fous là je pense
que c'est très compliqué avec pose une
question à tort puisque tu connais est
ce que l'émission de danse épaisseur ou
bien est-ce que ça s'essoufflerait pas
aussi un petit parce qu'on en a pas
d'urgence mais bien sûr que ça
s'essouffle
on arrive à la raison c'est sa démission
parce que sur été en urgence et une
blouse de rupture de contrat le collet
d'un voile
voilà c'est la vingt neuvième saison aux
états unis qui a commencé à être tourné
depuis septembre et mai prouver ils ont
serré america lui est gay